[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
this course covers the key steps to
adopting agile development
in your api program from our combined
experience at google
the first start to any adoption is a
mindset shift
agile software development just makes
sense if you've been through traditional
waterfall development
you know about the big handovers big
team silos
and difficulty in collaborating and plan
change
the values and principles espoused in
this manifesto
where derive and underpin a broad range
of software development frameworks
but primarily seek to solve the root
causes of the software development and
waterfall
the term agile was popularized but the
manifesto for agile software development
take a moment to read through it and
visit their website
agile can be adopted in many different
software settings within the digital
value chain
for our course we focus on the agile
method
of developing apis by the api team
a core part of agile is to have one
cross-functional api team
this means the api team should be
largely self-sufficient
with as few dependencies as possible
here's what the agile api team would
look like
the core api team is in the middle with
one team made up of the api
product owner api developers qa
engineers
and scrum master in the inner ring
they are constantly working together the
outer ring
represents also core team members who
may not be fully dedicated to the api
team
it might be partially allocated over
time to support multiple api teams
the role of connecting with non-core
team members
are represented with arrows showing
specific individuals
who should take ownership of these key
activities
we explore each one of the roles and
relationships in depth throughout this
course
for teams starting out with agile one of
the biggest pitfalls
is taking on too much scope a great way
to adapt to changing plans
is to reduce the size of each software
scope implement
developing software in a new way can be
difficult for inexperienced teams
so a smaller scope is even more ideal
for them
size the scope of your api project right
and focus on the
minimum viable product ask your team
what is the lease we need to build that
will still deliver business value
the picture here shows three different
ways to build a transport device
over four releases with the business
goal of getting from point a
to point b the first example should be
avoided
which is building incrementally after
each release
there's no business value since we only
get from point a
to b until the very end in release 4.
the second example is better it achieves
the goal of getting from a to b
in each release with a working device
but it forces the team to rework the
product
in every release leading to a lot of
waste and throwaway effort
the third example is the mvp approach
we can transport from a to b in each
release
but we have minimal rework since we're
build on top of the previous releases
functionality
in a smart sequence you can think of
agile api development in just this way
deliver the right mvp and pay close
attention to the sequence
you are releasing your new apis to be
really efficient it's not enough to
release often
but to release with quality and with the
least amount of effort
instead of writing test cases after
development is complete
write the test cases and define the
success criteria upfront
in design before the development starts
this practice comes in two flavors
test driven development and
behavior-driven development
both are very similar and achieve the
same outcome
both methods output code that can then
be automated by qa engineers
who can string together a series of unit
tests and
tests written through tdd or bdd
to becoming integration level tests for
the api
by writing test cases that are
programmable scripts
we can run the tests over and over again
taking a huge load off the traditional
qa bottleneck
and makes turnarounds on the qa feedback
loop incredibly fast
for more information about testing refer
to the qa strategy course
later on this series the principle of
automation
is quality is an essential part of agile
transformation
no other practice represents us better
than setting up a continuous integration
and continuous deployment pipeline this
shortened acronym is cicd
the main goal is to prevent integration
hell where multiple developers
begin integrating large chunks of code
near the later phases of the project
to avoid this drama the picture to the
left illustrates a recurring cycle
from code check-in to testing to
deployment of the api bundle to updating
the api documentation the purpose to do
this cycle
on a frequent basis or even on a per
code commit basis
by using software like jenkins and
programming to move code from each one
of these steps
this process can be largely automated
this reduces human effort
and increases the frequency that this
cycle is run so the errors are caught
early starting from the first week of
coding this practice of mastering the ci
cd pipeline
is essential in adopting agile
development
now that we have a good grasp of the
fundamental strategies and tactics of
adopting agile let's discuss the process
of implementation
here's the familiar waterfall process
long release
with lengthy stages and big handover
points often from one team to another
with risk and unknowns unsurfaced until
we get into that particular stage
you've probably been through it and have
some pretty interesting stories to tell
teams that move away from waterfall have
a tendency to move into scrum
fall it breaks the work into sprints
and starts testing cycles early on so it
helps the team pivot
and provide early visibility to progress
however because testing is separated as
a post sprint activity
and not included during requirements
definition and sprints
testing in bug fix time is elongated and
long release cycles invariably happen
if you have large scope that you can't
break apart
this is still better than waterfall
however
with api development and most software
development
we can definitely go further than scrum
fall the first important tactic
to avoid scrum fall is to merge
development and qa
into one sprint this likely means
you will take on less work in the sprint
to give time for bug fixing
but with testing and fixing merged into
the sprint
you've tested and ready for to release
functionality at the end of each sprint
this gives us the real ability to pivot
make this
your first goal for the team just
testing furiously during development
isn't enough we need to incorporate the
principle of definition of quality up
front
if developers are not fully aware of the
test criteria
or qa engineers have to spend more of
their time defining the test criteria
in the sprint precious time will be
wasted in the sprint
have the qa engineers and the developers
work
with the requirements to define the test
criteria ahead of the sprint
this can be done using test driven
development method
or the behavior-driven development we
spoke about earlier
go as far as having the test scripts
coded so that the q engineers are just
making
minor modifications in the sprint itself
with testing definition brought up
in between requirements and sprints your
last step is to automate the ci cd
pipeline
don't shortcut or give up on laying down
the foundation for automation
testing and optimizing the team's
process
with time your team will come to trust
the process as the testing begins to
speed up
development and quality now that we have
a higher level approach down
let's dive a bit deeper into the agile
process
there are two common variant processes
in agile
scrum and kanban please take a moment to
read the descriptions
while scrum has more processes with more
steps to take into account
the cycle of development is more
familiar to many teams and more friendly
for new teams being formed
kanban although easy to pick up relies
on work
that are smaller chunks of effort and
less dependent on other work
teams that have been working well
together who can really self-manage and
agile
may be better at picking up kanban
for the purpose of this course we will
focus on scrum
given its complexity and higher rates of
adoption
whichever process you pick commit to it
don't switch back and forth
until you really feel like the team has
lived and learned through that process
since the scrum process can be quite
complex we're going to step through this
process
one at a time a product owner is the
starting point at step
one it all begins with a vision
from this vision we develop an api
roadmap
this should be a high level scope of the
components needed to achieve this vision
and deliver value for the organization
this roadmap can include
different sets of apis business adoption
apps usage key compliance efforts
infrastructure and even improvements to
the developer portal
with a product roadmap focus on what
will be the first valuable release
keep in mind the mvp principle
now that you have the scope of your
first release it should be quickly
turned into a
ranked list of requirements in step two
these requirements are written in the
form of
epics and user stories often at this
point
the habit is to go into a lot of
requirements detail
don't instead of going deep list
all the high level features and
requirements if you're spending more
than a week on this
you're likely going too deep step 3
is where most the recurring action
process happens
the api team will select the most
important user stories to work on
for the coming sprint the user stories
have to be fully fleshed out with
business
technical and testing details the api
team will review each user story
break down the activities into tasks
needed to build this user story
estimate the effort and commit to a set
of user stories for the next sprint
each sprint can be one to four weeks in
length
but we often see teams settle on two
weeks as the happy medium
at the end of the sprint the user
stories should be completed
and ready for go live anything not
finished will be carried over to the
next
rent or place back to the product
backlog
this sprint cycle repeats itself again
throughout the sprint cycle the scrum
master is the coach
and tracks the team's productivity
through burn down and burn up charts
to measure the team's progress in the
form of velocity
we will cover velocity later in this
course in addition to tracking
progress several ceremonies are core to
scrum
these key ceremonies are listed in steps
four
five and six in step four the daily
scrum
is a daily 30-minute activity where each
member talks about the progress they
made
their task for the day and any blockers
this is the time for the team to take
the pulse of the progress
and drive action and ask for help
in step 5 a sprint review also known as
the sprint demo
occurs at the end of the sprint it's
generally meant to recap
what has been built and provides a
moment to celebrate and to publicize
the achievements of the team in step six
the sprint retrospective is a ceremony
also at the end of the sprint
the teams comes together to self-reflect
on what went well
and what could be improved oftentimes
the best improvements
come from a team retro one area of
confusion we encounter
is what happens in between the steps
from product backlog
to finish work the ceremonies are fairly
easy to understand
but the sequence can be a bit tricky to
visualize
let's unpack this a bit more taking
another view
of a sprint by sprint you will see a
repeating pattern
where the product backlog items are
refined prior to the start of
development
this repeating effort is called backlog
refinement
a team process that is usually
established in the beginning of the
project
is called the definition of ready
this checklist is the agreement within
the team
a winning story is refined enough for
the developers and the qa engineers
to start the sprint thus this is a clear
target
for even the team members doing
refinement on how far they need to go
to meet the definition of ready
refinement is a collaborative activity
it's very important that the product
owner
api architect and qa engineer all focus
on the same set of user stories
in the priority order of the backlog
after they are done with refining
s1 they move on to s2 and refine
that set this continues until the
backlog is all refined
once a set of user stories in sprint 1
is refined sprint planning starts as
either a recurring activity before the
sprint
in small chunks or one larger session at
the first activity of the sprint
the output of sprint planning is a full
set of tasks per user story
with this the team goes to work on
development and test scripts
writing and execution this process
continues iteratively
in sprint 2 3 and so forth
the team also needs to set the
definition of done for a user story at
the start of the project
this is the line for the team to draw in
terms of the standard
of finish and quality that should be
adhered to
this way there's no misunderstanding at
the end of the sprint when a user story
is marked done
it's up to the team as a whole to
enforce the standard
in the last step finish work can be
queued
for product release and bundled in the
release per sprint
the automated ci cd pipeline helps the
last leg of process
quickly flow from test and approve code
into the main branch
we cover a ton of concepts and
strategies in this course
to summarize create cross-functional
teams
and close the ties between it and
business
avoid legacy and waterfall processes so
you can deliver
smaller scope and pivot on a regular
basis
always look for ways to automate and
reduce any big handovers
use methods like behavior-driven
development
and concepts like definition of ready
and definition of done
to build quality into the process and
align the teams
on a shared expectation don't worry
you won't get it perfect on day one use
the feedback loops like the sprint
ceremonies to take feedback and optimize
every agile team will tailor their
process over time
if there's one more last principle of
agile
to remember it is about continuous
improvement
that's your north star i hope this
course has helped you get a firmer grasp
on transforming into an agile
development team
if you want more information please
check out the community for
ebooks articles and other related topics
you